ja also ich bin aus dem bereich der
pädagogik und werden deshalb nun
versuchen von diesen keller georgischen
link wegen hier auf die thematik zu
reden mit den gegenstands bereichen
lernen
120 vor zwei hoffnung den studentenjob
beworben und zwar in einem von
studierenden geführten unternehmen das
er extra these
die studierenden aus anderen
fachbereichen unternehmen zu beraten
ein sehr erfolgreiches und zeitgemäßes
unternehmen der studierenden in zürich
und er sagte beim vorstellungsgespräch
habe nämlich gesagt ich viel kann man in
zürich gleich wenn man konnte überrascht
und dann hat es ist möglichst kreativ
erinnere sind hinweise geben die zweite
frage warum wir haben die leute zu
lackieren
da auch er dafür nicht versuchen zeit zu
ende sondern moment nicht ungewöhnlich
sondern sie kennen das von strukturen
sollten zeigen dass in der lage ist
wirklich innovative lösungsstrategien zu
generieren
wir müssen schulen aussehen ist sie
aussehen die kinder dort vorbereiten
mit diesen neuen anforderungen gerecht
zu werden welche sind das überhaupt was
müssen können tun können was davon
wollen die musikschule gelernt
und wie sollte ich künftig aussehen
welche neuen aufgaben kommen auf der
klasse dazu braucht man übernommen und
werde die besondere wollen können hier
digitale medien spiel vor allem im
kontext einer schreibenden handy hotel
unter dem kinn fall ist eher
unwahrscheinlich uns erreichen immer als
wer über eine option als eigenschaft von
objekten ohne bezug zum subjekt als
erstes reaktivierung von bestehen
diese sichtweise geht eine er eigentlich
mit der reduktion von bildung auf einem
mädchen treffen statt über kein von
innen anders auf alles was produziert
was ist für mich immer was planbar und
verwertbar ist oder auch etwas was dann
aus dem strich linden stattfinden kann
von institutionen in maker says ist in
versen barcamps da diese kultur
verstimmt und der kreativen
konstruktiven umgang mit technologie
ähnlichen schulen passe und immer mehr
technik begeisterte der eltern ihre
kinder im sogenannten digital mehr
bestellungen als ich selber
selbstbestimmt und autonom in einer
digitalisierten welt wahrnehmen und sich
ist auch für ihre kinder wirklich ja und
der klemme gehen in schulen mit einem
instrumentelle frauen der mediennutzung
diese praxis städten und eine und/oder
digitalität gingen über den begriff der
finne gesteigert 2016 kann dann morgen
sich eben nicht nur das gehör der
thermischen sondern in kulturellen
marketing entwickeln die einfach da sind
aus dem man auch nicht hinaus finden
kann indem retouren verstanden als summe
von außen prozessen geteilte bedeutung
und tierversuch grundsicherung bestimmt
werden und heilen zu einigen
die sind teilweise abgeschlossen und
richten sich in münchen und leipzig
norman und dieser prozess letztendlich
die abgeschlossenen nicht abgeschlossen
so dass wir machen so aus was ist jetzt
nun derzeitig not sexualisieren
digitalisierung ausgegangen
wie sieht eigentlich alles klassenzimmer
aus wie und wo sollte er wieder zum
einsatz kommen und was und wie sollen
lernen und natürlich auch wie sollen sie
letztendlich in digitalen medien um
geben und alles was ist ein fortune
unternehmer in italien letztlich bis
heute wunderbare bearbeitet der
abdeckung und wünsche in der nacht
verbreiteten ganze ich habe es an einer
schule in welche epoche bad liebenzell
und das was wir hier machen ist dass wir
kinder innerhalb von vier der andere
fahrer an den tag wenn man mehr daraus
gehören in vier jahren als genau das
machen werden wie sie das
die ganze mannschaft sitzt in ihrem
arbeitsfeld auch zu zweit kooperativ
aber letztendlich ist das immer noch
eine reform einen ausdruck unserer
aktuellen lernkultur anbieter eine
verbindung zwischen den elementen
begriffen zu lernen und kultur also
zwischen werken in die wiederum
stattfinden der tätigkeit und dem
historisch gewachsenen und auch anderen
setting innerhalb dessen diese technik
kann letztendlich die stattfinden und
von dem sie inhaltlich beeinflussen und
in deutschland hat sich jetzt seit 1900
nach verkäufer eine lernzeit
ausgebildete eben doch einen grund
gerade an letzten nationalisierung
nachricht und bildungsplan zertifizieren
und unbemerkt stehlen und behalten auch
mit einer differenzierung
daran kann man erkennen aber noch weit
ist ja auch lohnt sich immer wieder
beobachten klar sie sollten ihre modelle
grundlage für diese konstruktion dieser
lernkultur entscheidung jedoch nach wie
vor mächtig historische
entwicklungsprozesse zu sein die auch
unter den bedingungen von
digitalisierung einsprühen sich
weiterhin aus ich möchte dazu ein
kleines einem ähnlich aufgenommen haben
er besteht aus antwort meine zwei
semester und hinaus antworten von
kindern in der nähe gerückt ich habe
zugesagt wie sie für dich lernen in der
schule aus nicht weil der auswahl der
antworten nicht selektiv vorgegangen
gesagt bekommen die nächste franz ich
war eigentlich sehr sehr ähnlich
ich würde
haben
dessen was schule ist die schule aus
dass es nach wie vor stabil
sowohl bei den ausgebildeten lehrkräfte
der schule sei es zu erlebt haben
bereits bei der nächsten generationen
die sind diese vorstellungen commission
cec weitergegeben haben
auch meine studierenden haben eine ganz
ähnliche vorstellung von lernen konnte
wir sind in erster linie aus den selbst
gemachten erfahrungen mensch große
schule aus so wünsche ich mir schule
deswegen werde ich sehen
das haben wir bei mir sind gefallen ist
ja alles gar nichts steckt ist aber
letztendlich oder produzieren wir uns
immer wieder selber
eigentlich sollte doch diese erfahrungen
der sogenannten die toilette ist grenzt
2001 formulieren der generation die von
geburt an mit informationen zu entkommen
wie könnte
die aufgewachsen ist das doch eigentlich
anders sein diese generation
vermeintlich natürlich versiert im
umgang mit technologie mit neuen
ansprechenden und lernen und doch viel
besser multitasking also die vorherige
generation eine generation sind diesen
digitale medien nur außerdem seien neben
uns damit die ergebnisse betrifft studie
anschauen aber zu lernzwecken werden wir
sind digitalen medien von innen oft
alleinerziehende besser eingesetzt
obwohl sind damit aufgewachsen
das erfolgt hier kaum ein transfer und
den freizeitbeschäftigungen medien auf
das lernen aus der privaten nutzung bei
den studierenden sind kaum feldgeräten
entstanden wie sie nun in der hochschule
erwartet werden das bestätigt
beispielsweise auch in welcher form das
digitalisieren von 2006 das ist nämlich
studierenden von heute das potenzial
digitaler technologien nicht ausschöpfen
in deutschland nutzen lediglich 21
prozent ein leises sprechen
digitale medien vorerst denkt natürlich
auch den dozierenden zusammen in deren
folge
und seminaren digitale medien keine
rolle stellen und zu nehmen manche
natürlich auch eine literaturrecherche
ich keine letzten monate die online nach
wie vor mit dem breiten
praxis aber zum anderen lassen sich
digitale medien in der lehre auch nicht
so einfach hin
das zeigt sich zum start ins jahr 2017
dass vor allem der einsatz sozialer
medien in der lehre als ich werde morgen
wird es den studierenden wir nicht so
leicht gefallen zu unterschreiten zu
differenzieren zwischen den privaten
kontext und sind professionell und 26
problem auch die entwendung des neuen
museums fairen stelle eine große oder
gemüse da kann also selbst stellen dass
nicht die technik 19 terminiert sondern
es in die gesellschaft in kulturen die
szenarien die unterwelt praktiken in dem
art zu bestimmen und folglich haben
studierenden zu keinen schwierigkeiten
geboten
soziale medien und die damit verbundenen
praktiken kommunikation kollaboration
für akademische texte zu identifizieren
und in folge selbstverständlich auch für
schulen und unsere was sich daraus
ergibt sich ein problem eine sogenannte
karte einen zudem den kompakten
inkompatible gleichzeitigkeit gezwungen
auch vorherrschende mediale praktiken
nämlich auf der einen seite ballten sich
laufend neue wenn ihr alle praktik neue
hand und schauen sondern muss anderen
seite bemüht sie schön und immer
verzweifelt um einen 7
einsatz von informations und
kommunikationstechnik
das problem ist dass die forscher video
lernt wurde 23 jahre wird nicht
unmittelbar anschluss an eine kultur der
digitalität digitalität ist aber auch
kämpfen dass man eigentlich ausschalten
kann oder er ist einfach nicht in
ordnung die ganze zeit beginnen
aber wie eine brücke zu fahren würde
solange nicht funktionieren solange
digitalität das eigentliche technische
objekte geschaffen wird so lange diese
dinge wie roboter karin beiden als man
es gegenüber versteht das instrument
eingesetzt wird und dem daraus daran
gemessen sind ob sich im unterricht
einen mehrwert ergibt oder und sich der
rechtshänder lehrkräfte in teilen
und optimieren lassen damit stellt das
dir getan in der kirche gegenüber
gestalter auch ein freund ist der
digitalität als kultur und performative
was und impliziert ein anderes
verständnis von lernen dass es nicht
mehr indiziert abläuft sondern im namen
einer entwicklung hin zu
individualisieren und
gemeinschaftlichkeit im körper motiven
dann bringen dieses foto motiv seines in
diesem zusammenhang ein zentrales
element einer neuen lernkultur in einer
welt die letztendlich so produktive
praktiken hergestellt meine these ist
dass aus pädagogischen perspektive der
fonds viel weniger ausgerichtet sein
sollte sich niemand jetzt mit whiteboard
und der wunderbaren momenten kamera oder
den tablet cent wegen umgegangen werden
soll sondern wie mit dem moment
unbestimmtheit mit dieser wohnung mit
undichte stelle
oder digital im hinblick auf bildung
gestaltet werden kann wenn du musst hier
in gesellschaftlichen und
transformationsprozesse sind aus und neu
bestimmt werden
wirbel hat beim bildungsgipfel 19
formulieren digitale transformation des
zu zählen und zu digitalisieren und zu
90 prozent tanzformationen und dem
besonders an hochschule und schule eine
zentrale strategie seien zunächst mal
den medialen charakter an
aller bildungsprozesse in den blick ins
blickfeld zu zuschauen was passierte
eigentlich darauf aufbauen können die
suche nach bestehenden praktiken
einsetzen
die eben dann mit technologien als
konstruktive aktuell weiter entrechtet
werden woraus sich neuen zielen unter
den bedingungen von der vitalität
arbeiten lassen und die bestehende und
technologien optimiert werden ich möchte
ihnen dies anhand eines beispiels
konkretisieren was sie jetzt gleich
sehen sind szenen aus einem seminar mit
dem thema in den medien
wer mir mit 90 kindern gearbeitet und
hier hinterlassen
und die haben sich überlegt wann habe
ich nicht in meinem leben schon mal
richtig stark brechen was war sein start
im moment in meinem leben
und diese geschichte über diese momente
haben sie importieren arbeitsformen
zunächst aufgeschnitten überarbeitet und
dann verfällt wirklich mit tablets
kindern an die kameraleute haben sie
überlegt ich stelle mir da alle sagen
in dem tempel und die rutsche gericht
haben sich überlegt wie kann ich das was
passiert letztendlich auch uns ist das
gleiche projekt in thailand statt kinder
mit teil an genau den stellen und selbst
noch laufen und am ende an den kinder in
deutschland mit den kindern in die
heimat ihre geschichten über skype
ausgetauscht
da sehen sie jetzt gleich zuerst ein
kurzer ausschnitt aus dem film eine
verleiht sind in der entstanden ist und
zum anderen aus und
[Musik]
nein
der unterricht der stadt gefunden haben
er hat sehr viel mit ihrer umwerfenden
erschaffen intervenieren zu tun
all das sind folgen des bebens aber auch
der transformation und digitale medien
wurden in keinster weise sendungen zähle
eingesetzt sondern sie ermöglichen
kindern neue linke auch in sich selbst
ich bin stark wie schafft das kann ein
film machen ich bin teil einer
legionellen serien somit anreiz zum
ausdruck zum nachdenken zum reflektieren
oder schule und unterricht immer geplant
ist immer durch stabile praktiken der
kunde bestimmt männer zeugen ergaben
sich hier kreativen und produktiven
möglichkeiten zusammen mit digitalen
medien in situationen und bestimmt die
ein von den akteuren sich wechselseitig
muss noch als solche erkannt werden der
kirchentag teilnehmen
aber während die jährliche programm
digitale bildung meistens die
bestimmtheit zu welchen blick leicht den
überblick leben geht es nicht darum dass
schülerinnen und schülern unterricht
eine situation zu erkennen und dann so
handeln wie schon in der badewelt wie
sie konditionieren in den wohnbereichen
nach wie vor stattfinden die in den
gruppen ersten durchbrochen werden sonst
das auch schwierig in digitalen medien
dementsprechend einzusetzen aber wenn
reflektiert wird über die eigene
lernkultur über die möglichkeiten die
hier vor allem der einsatz digitaler
medien finden kann dann kann es
letztendlich auch gelingen kulturen neu
auszuloten
dieser von motive und lagen mit
unbestimmtheit bisher eher als form
eines initiativen handelns dem fertigen
10 nach allerdings die sich dann
konstitutiver auch in unsere interaktion
und beziehungen mischt und diese dann
gegenüber in klassischen anhalts und
produktionsorientierten den umgang
nehmen beispielsweise spinne argentinien
weit hinaus diese kalkulierte
individualisierte lernen das
normalerweise den ungarn italien
zugesprochene stehen diesem lernen in
der gemeinschaft aber keineswegs
grundsätzlich entgegen denn erst in der
gemeinschaft keine namen arbeitsteiligen
kooperationen lernen über kollektive
reflexion gegenseitige unterstützung und
beck im analogen und digitalen
umgebungen kann dann auch selbst
organisiertes lernen letztendlich
offenen und regionaler fand der
einzelnen länder fordern deswegen keine
kurze
ich entscheide ob und jetzt der
heterogenität der schülerschaft mit
einem technischen verständnis von
individualisierung begegnen oder
systemen kreativen praktiken hier zum
einsatz kommen kann man unterschiedliche
schwerpunkte setzen ich sehe vor allem
im bereich der diagnose oder bei seiner
vorstellung attraktive lernmaterialien
großes sozialwahlen in der lebensmittel
intelligenz auch dazu kurzes beispiel
ausbildern in dem hier kleine roboter
immer wünschenswert
[Musik]
das sind der 3
oder ausprobieren
natürlich
[Musik]
hier ist ein verständnis wie viele
aussehendes klassenzimmern was lernen
bedeutet und es geht hier meiner meinung
nach und wein mehr
also mein geld schnell zur motivation
und lippen was ist das überhaupt nicht
es geht um das bestehen einer
digitalisierung nett und das begleitende
funktion digitale artefakte um die
beteiligungs- und kirchliche prägung
selbst die hier geleistet werden muss
auch und die chance zertifizierte
lernangebote die lassen im kooperativen
austauschprozesse anregen können aber es
geht nicht darum eigentlich machen zu
können um dadurch den kindern
möglichkeiten zukunft zu verändern
es geht und partizipation und nachdenken
und reflexion
doch auch ein einsatz digitaler medien
zu schlafen aber weit mehr
es ist ein trugschluss anzunehmen dass
eine homogene einheit liche lernkultur
unter den bedingungen der digitalität
anzustreben des lernens bedeutungs
aushandeln muss felix stalder offen
gesagt hatten erst über eine
vollständige einbindung digitaler medien
können sich diese kollektive teilen lang
halten dann auch auf vielfältige weise
verändern aber nur dann wenn sich die
lernen
wenn sich die das bestellte den
straßenlärm nennt ist die schulen aus
den nicht verändern
dann werden die digitalen medien
letztendlich ihren consozial nicht
entfalten können was er sagt aber in
schulen brauchen ist der mut zum risiko
neue wege zu gehen mit kindern gemeinsam
in den zunehmend digitalisierten welt zu
gestalten und war an der unamid
unbestimmtheit der verarbeitungsprozess
soll dank digitales mit lantinus und
durch dazu mit prozessen eingesetzt
werden hinter zu denen bereits
ausschließlich vorhandene bildungsziele
zu erfüllen damit dem den der lampe
den bedingungen
von digitalität nicht gerecht wir wissen
jetzt ein nicht welche anforderungen die
kinder 30 jahren gegenüber stehen aber
sie sind bereit ist jetzt anders sind
neue anforderungen veränderte anfangen
um den boden zu beginn eines vortrags zu
spannen des landes funktioniert in
sprints unterrichten vergangenen
jahrhunderte vorher schütte soziale und
kommunikative nachdenken außen vor zu
lassen so eine grundschule aber steckte
sie es jetzt braucht es die bereitschaft
sicheren bildungs auch keine
grundsätzliche gedanken zu machen welche
werte bleiben stehen welche im neuen
formen des lehrens und lernens ganis
umzusetzen
ich bin der meinung dass schule in der
herkömmlichen form ein auslaufmodell ist
wenn es nicht gelingt kinder aus den
veränderungen eine minute
das sicherheitssystem zu wissen da ist
die folgen nicht auf
unsere
ausgenommen
nicht nur die männer diesen zeiten
geschlossen
zum beispiel haben soll
die kunden fragen aufgeworfen hat und
wir haben
essen
[Musik]
kenner wissen
und statt zu lassen
[Musik]
gewinnen die studenten
wie rasant die seit 1
und ich hoffe dass dieses wissen und die
menschen den großen prozess
ja ist entstanden wenn diese prozesse
den patienten stattfinden
und es ist auch die frage wer man nun
nennen hier aus also ende natürlich
ausnahmen das schon wer unterwegs
fortschritte in einem gruppe von
personen die sehr einheitlich mit
unbehagen wie beispielsweise auch bei
der gestaltung von lehrplänen und ihn
auch mit einem ziel instrument
ausrichten wird nicht interessiert und
dann vergebenen chance endlich
eigentlich etwas ganz anderes zu machen
natürlich wichtig und digitalisierung
das ist ein anlass aber diese
digitalisierung das ist ja auch nicht
das was man aus dem es ist passt sehr
gut zusammen
aber es wäre jetzt und sein
neben zu machen was wir können das
leisten was tun dass es sich weder
können
und ja noch immer noch fanden ist nach
wie vor aber es ist sich grundsätzlich
etwas ändern dass sich nun angehen und
in sich
was ist eigentlich mit angeben was
selbst bestimmen kann
deswegen habe ich versucht dieses medien
thema mit allen ernstes weil ich
wahrzunehmen selbstbestimmt in der
digitalen welt stark genauso richtig
lesen und schreiben kann und das sind
irgendwann folgen die man mit bedenken
muss unter den bedingungen eine kultur
es ist universell
von diesen die gedanken gehen wir uns
machen müssen wie schulen und draußen in
die tiefe und wenn ich jetzt hier mit
allen leuten vom ministerium unterhalte
die sagen die digitalen terrestrischen
links handel kommen
[Musik]
aber ist das eventuell ins special unser
ausschließen die beiden überhaupt nicht
gebaut wird
das ist nämlich das haben wir bei
lehrerin
zu den sanktionen gestimmt wir haben
nichts ist natürlich im gespräch zu tun
es gibt hier strecke gegenüber
wunderbare zeiten
das hat mit der real bedeutete für den
geplanten kinderhaus und sprachlich
empfang den kommentar
aber das ist alles betteln verkrustete
strukturen geben welchen bereichen
verlieren also genau untersuchen die
kreation und technische situation
herzustellen weil ich weiß dass mich
erzählen macht euch locker der hund ist
diese geschichte großen ziel so versuche
ich auch digitale medien einzusetzen
nicht
damit die kinder vor gering sind und
später programmieren werden sondern weil
man damit wunderbar kommunizieren kann
ford oder natürlich bin ich auch
motiviert aber dass das nicht bis es das
hauptziel sondern im bett und so erleben
wie eine eine welt in der nicht immer im
leben wenn er sie auch kompetent
begleitet werden von leuten hier aber
auch diese entsprechende praktiken wenn
es denn gelegen
und dass ich häufig das problem dass ich
auch gerade meine studierenden anschauen
das sind sehr traditionell meisten
zunahmen in diesen beruf ergreifen weil
sie sich an den rollen weil sie ihren
sicheren zunächst wollen und welchen
selber durch diesen gefallen hat
wir haben
ist ja auch sehr leben mit dem kind das
will ich überhaupt nicht darum geht es
ihm aber die anforderungen an leute die
die eine liste von einem leben den ich
sagen die zeugen zufolge entstand und am
ende und man merkt zu sehen habe ich
geld ein sondern das ist unseren
projekten schau mal wer hat er in der
erben könnte dann ebenfalls passiert hat
und plötzlich fangen den kindern zu
kommunizieren zufolge wurden auch
kritisch zu denken und dem feld gesehen
und seinen posten ist jetzt aber nix da
müssen wir noch mal ran da von dem ich
mich also da geht es nicht nur um etwas
zu erreichen sondern die kinder sich in
diesem als entwickelt ein junge hat
gesagt ich hab keine so ein erlebnis wo
ich dachte immer lebens alles deswegen
ließ
doch überlegt wie kann ich nicht so
darstellen und am schluss alle
geklatscht leerstand formen der hc
starck erlebt doch dieses unglück mit
digitalen geht im glas ist es losgeht
und nicht ich setze das tablet ein und
damit mache ich etwas besser das ist
vorher auch schon sondern ist wenn sich
neue ziele die wir noch gar nicht kennen
aber es ist jetzt an der zeit dass wir
uns gedanken machen
und so
wenn sie so ein polizist
und 15
um
die andere auf